[Music]
in gone missing news reporting the news
like that TIF [ __ ] submitted by Shark
Week is it Shark Week for me it is right
now why you so mean we just started that
very very pleasant for being under when
did you just start you could be worried
I'm just playing I'm just wait is that
why you're glowing Oh Willie you are
glowing oh thank you did you see I set
this full up and then he just spikes it
yeah dude
damn come in and clutch that means you
could give me a [ __ ] thank you
well I don't want to have sex you're
bleeding everywhere but then her mouth
isn't bleeding oh my god can't make my
mouth bleed I know it's bad thank you so
much for the sister all the girls right
now are like lucky probably girls that
do want to suck their dicks but yeah if
I take a shower smells good it smells
like soap and [ __ ] still dirty dick
yeah remember it's not circumcised so
adult hustle the whole don't smell the
whole I'm like your dick is here and I'm
like cartoon nose pinched I'm down
really she got the clothespin I got a
smell my own dick then it's not long
enough to know if you are going to get
too big suck remember it's very polite
to wash yeah I wash it like crazy it
smells bad for us
because I wash to the point where I'm
almost jacking it off I mean keeping
your eyeballs [ __ ] stroke that [ __ ]
real good you know you gotta use some of
that soap get up in there and just clean
that [ __ ] out what the [ __ ] are you
turning the volume is there masculine
wash you know there's like feminine wash
yeah is there masculine washer can just
use the feminine wash what are we even
talking about smelly my kids pity you
would saying I could finally suck his
dick like I earned the right week Shark
Week that's where it came from on it are
you happy submitter
you really dinner the sister of a guy
who vanished from a music festival face
you may have what the [ __ ] happened here
what the [ __ ] now you guys look tired as
[ __ ] you looked all like professional
and clean looking and also you look
tired as a mother conversation was so
funny the [ __ ] reflective center of a
guy who vanished the sister of a guy who
vanished from a music festival thinks he
may have joined a cult oh okay I just
think he's had a good time could I
imagine the fifteen-year-old me right
when I used to go to music festivals
make all kinds of friends on truck and
if I was there and someone's like follow
me to this promised land and we're gonna
[ __ ] pray underneath the waterfall and
[ __ ] each other's brains up apart what
it doesn't wait what where's the [ __ ]
tubs brand up doesn't like that Colts
always do that they don't pitch it that
way really that cult leader [ __ ]
everybody yeah but it's not [ __ ] each
other's brains out okay fine but it's
job no but it's still a cool experience
for a guy to try [ __ ] me what is going
on
right now I'm so gonna call the [ __ ] it
depends on what kind of cult we're
talking about here a lot is it the
suicide cult is it the cults a lot of
coats the cult leader wants to [ __ ]
everybody guys and girls yes so I've
never had that guy try to [ __ ] me before
but imagine if someone try to [ __ ] me
that right now my love the cult
I know but of the crease in the
waterfall and from the waterfall right
cuz they're always in the lake with the
[ __ ] waterfall and there's always
some person with like a ring of flowers
around like an old beat-up school bus
right yes school that's really yeah boy
you threw him off there like Bubble Boy
remember where you would Park at this
waterfall place where you park the
school bus
they call you gotta transport a lot of
people choo-choo-choo okay seventeen car
and they're gonna be singing songs on
the way to the water that makes your
back look I know I'm back and I just
imagine if I was on ecstasy it
everything just feels good and there's a
dude that's gonna [ __ ] my mic at me dude
because that's what you see thugs
[ __ ] massaging each other and [ __ ]
that make for a cool story yeah you
don't mind other guys on you and you
know when you're on ecstasy getting
touched there's a [ __ ] blown
out awesome experience you could be like
the toughest dude with tattoos but
you'll be sucking on a pacifier or they
don't let you do that anymore but back
in the day yeah we had these [ __ ]
beads necklaces with a pacifier that you
sucking on and then you have five homies
just massaging the [ __ ] out of you so
you're like King gorilla right like
right here but you have like five other
gangsters just rubbing the [ __ ] out of
your shoulders and [ __ ] you're just
like damn you alpha dude [ __ ] yeah
that's really gross
yeah and then you trade and you just
trade and everybody just massages the
[ __ ] out of each other and I'd be a
really cool perspective to have on life
that's the most gangster thing I ever
heard of my bro alright so this dude
here his name is Kevin
years old from Michigan he went to the
electric forest festival oh that sounds
fun
it does sound fun it's an eight-day wait
to weekend event rays are getting longer
and longer and like festivals are just
crazy there's no two weeks like that
yeah is it just on the weekend well it's
two weekends but people stay in the area
too and just party all [ __ ] week
I can't even last that long I think the
the most I've been rolling was like four
days straight oh my god I thought I was
gonna die yes this dude he had an
argument with his girlfriend and told
her that he was returning to his tents
that's the best place to have argument
to cuz it's so loud no cuz then you
could just have sex with another girl
Wow the first thought you have yeah cuz
you're out there open with their growth
aren't they trying to do orgies there's
like orgy tents and stuff like that I
think that's just like Burning Man or
some other [ __ ] this might just be a
regular music festival you think some
wild [ __ ] doesn't know what those things
are for what not for the music is just a
more geez I don't know I never been to a
music festival where there's orgies the
forest part of it the forest part of it
what about okay
he's thinking it's an underground like
what I'm thinking crazy ass for but I'm
thinking like a EDC that I was 2,000
acre grounds yeah I was thinking like
Burning Man but in a connect forest
forest forest man yeah with like [ __ ]
Douglas Douglas firs and [ __ ] the
Ponderosa is you know [ __ ] read
a lot of brochures and Yosemite kind of
impressed soon were first dating and
we're gonna pick out a Christmas tree
he's like a ponderosa or what's other
one fir yeah Douglas fir housing the Boy
Scouts
that merely got you Doha I was in the
Boy Scouts so I had to memorize all
kinds of plants and trees issues my god
damn he's sophisticated it's a deciduous
kevin is oh he looks like so they're
saying that he just disappeared after
that festival like after he had that
argument with this girl he's just
missing oh that's not good he didn't
disappear he literally broke up with her
and just went away
oh he ghosted her ass all the hardest go
started he goes to his family's yeah he
cleaned out his bank accounts and
everything ghosts so why did they go to
cult because his sister said that the
people that were there mentioned that
this particular cult that is known to
have a bus at these music festivals that
they were at that music festival and
they're gonna go to a waterfall crew
people from festival yeah that sure
looked like the cat books on Totoro and
[ __ ] yeah if I saw that bus at a music
festival I would throw up my II go on
the bus and then put the e back to my
mother so I can start all over again
oh my god if I saw that bus I'd [ __ ]
force myself into the cult and it don't
kick me out so the girlfriend said that
he had been acting odd all week and I
was a good girl thing oh so they were at
the festival and then he like started
kicking it with them and then at that
point he started being weird it hasn't
been like fully confirmed like she
hasn't been kicking it with him I just
said his sister thinks that he joined
the cult because of other people saying
that this cult was there mmm oh so he
was accusing his girlfriend of having a
sexual relationship with another friend
that was at the festival possible
yeah that's when they got an argument
and then he also had issues with alcohol
substance abuse that's a prerequisite
for festivals oh yeah he had been
treated for bipolar and that he also
identified himself as an atheist he
stopped taking his prescribed medication
roughly two months before he disappeared
well she's a lucky girl huh you made him
lethargic yeah
so he's like possibly in a manic state
and he's like thinking it's a good idea
to go joined the
Christian group oh it's a cult oh but
yeah wait my news atheists right yeah
that's why I was here that's one crazy
party he also talked about his desire to
grow marijuana to a friend this guy
sounds like a normal guy I'm sorry it
doesn't sound a bipolar dude that does a
lot of drugs and alcohol and then likes
to go to music festivals and then the
one that scares me though is the
atheists that turned into a Christian
yeah that's the creepy that's the creepy
part yeah unless the girl you fall in
love with this Christian you're just
really fine there's anything guys can
change like that's how you convert
people to religion you get a hot-ass
girl yeah you could make a guy do any
that's like a guy when he dates a vegan
and he becomes obsessed to begin because
if the girls like unless he's be joy he
doesn't give a [ __ ] oh yeah tries a
player I mean is well I don't really
consider Kim that much of a vegan she's
not a hardcore yet those peakins all
right fine
Vietnamese people we don't give the
credit of each choice the father of the
ex-girlfriend who he lived in the same
house as he did for 18 months he thinks
that he walked away with the plan in
mind that he purposely did it to make
people think that he died oh he likes
those I mean now we're talking about him
because it would work I think what he
wanted was a little bit of attention cuz
he has a broken little heart you know
cooking will ya and then people do these
kind of things because it's like look at
me world I'm a help please somebody help
me and that's what what's really going
on here if I was like Jesus I would be
like give me your tire sick and hungry
[ __ ] but in reality well I'm not Jesus
so then I'm I'm just I'm not even the
[ __ ] Statue of Liberty where it's
like the [ __ ] sick and everybody's
welcome here
I'm the opposite I only want top-notch
[ __ ] around me so you're Hitler
I'm like yeah
a hundred percent but then the problem
with healer was he was trying to burn
some people and I don't like that
because I think Jewish people are cool
but anyways this guy I would not want
him around my circle of friends he would
be one of the first people that I kick
out from my life cuz I'd be like man you
got too many problems will you literally
talk to yourself we're about a minute
ahead
what's the craziest diatribe that was
weird [ __ ] was know how to respond
that's homeless Joe dude right there ma
dude let him get it out
yep
[Music]